sans surprise le front président
français lui coûte sa place
la république en marche prend acte que
cédric villani n'est plus membre du
parti un communiqué du bureau exécutif
qui prend bien soin de ne pas employer
le mot exclusion pour les marcheurs le
député de l'essonne s'est lui un séparer
du mouvement présidentiel et les fn qui
considère même avoir tendu la main à
cédric villani jusqu'au bout dimanche
dernier le candidat dissident à la
mairie de paris avait été reçu par
emmanuel macron le président lui avait
alors demandé de se rapprocher de
benjamin griveaux candidat
officiellement investi par lrm en
juillet dernier emmanuel macron n'a pas
réussi à trouver les arguments pour
convaincre cédric villani
au lendemain de cette tentative ratée de
conciliation d'un jean d'un griveaux a
pris son téléphone et essayer de joindre
en vain nos candidats dissidents
il a donc profité d'un rassemblement des
marcheurs lundi soir pour faire passer
un message assez de recul et je sais
pour avoir eu l'occasion de le
fréquenter
moi aussi à quel point
cédric peut-être attachant je sais
qu'ils ont sans doute aimé chez lui ce
qu'il ne retrouvait pas chez moi
davantage de naturel une part de
fantaisie et peut-être aussi d'émotivité
ils nous en manquent
quelques-uns ce soir ne nous voilons pas
la face
ne nous racontons pas d'histoires ce
sont celles et ceux qui ont rejoint
l'aventuré initiée par cédric villani et
ce soir c'est à eux que je veux
m'adresser
je veux leur dire
je comprends la démarche qui a été la
leur malgré sa popularité dans de
nombreux rangs de la majorité cédric
villani semble plus que jamais isolé
plusieurs macro nist considère que le
député de l'essonne a franchi la ligne
rouge en maintenant coûte que coûte sa
candidature à la mairie de paris
peu importe cédric villani est un homme
libre aujourd'hui selon l'un de ses
porte parole entre l'appartenance un
appareil politique et l'engagement pour
la ville le mathématicien choisi selon
ses mots de rester fidèle aux
parisiennes et aux parisiens en
s'opposant à la volonté présidentielle
cédric villani a ravivé la crise au sens
même de la majorité présidentielle à un
mois et demi des municipales l'enjeu est
de taille avec cette affaire ce qui se
joue est la possibilité pour elles et
roem de remporter la mairie de paris ou
de la perdre autre ville qui montrent la
fragilité au sein du parti
biarritz dans la cité basque deux
membres du gouvernement étaient prêts à
s'affronter sur deux listes concurrentes
ce mercredi l'exécutif a sifflé la fin
de la partie
l'elysée fait savoir que ni le ministre
de l'agriculture didier guillaume ni le
secrétaire d'état chargé du commerce
extérieur jean baptiste lemoyne ne
seront finalement candidat
[Musique]